alors c'est le réel vous êtes donc
chargé des affaires de l'enseignement
scolaire dans ces affaires de pédophilie
convient de voir on a plus en plus
d'instituteurs de professeurs de
proviseur de l'inspecteur d'académie qui
demande bien quel doit être leur
conduite à tenir
qu'est-ce qu'il va d'abord ce que nous
leur avons redit ce matin c'est que la
maltraitance sur les enfants et
notamment la maltraitance sexuelle est
un fléau social très lourd en france
puisque on estime à 1 enfant sur dix le
nombre d'enfants qui subissent ce type
de sévices
c'est dire l'importance du phénomène le
gouvernement a décidé de faire reculer
ce fléau social
il y aura d'ailleurs à l'automne un
projet de loi à son arc la prévention et
la répression
les atteintes sexuelles sur les enfants
avec elisabeth guigou ministre de la
justice et pour la première fois dans un
gouvernement éducation et justice
travaillent la main dans la main donc
les choses vont bouger vous pouvez
compter sur nous je viens de la question
oui encre et mans on est professeur
professeur de lycée on apprend quelque
chose enfin qu'elle est suspicion de la
part de parents d'enfants sur un
professeur qu'est ce qu'on fait on
alerte qui et dans quel délai il y a
deux types de choses que l'on apprend
dans l'école l'école est un lieu de
protection pour l'enfant qui subit des
violences dans la famille 80% des cas
donc c'est un lieu de sécurité et en
même temps c'est un lieu aussi où
l'enfant peut subir les violences
sexuelles de la part d'adultes
il est important de garder à l'esprit
cet équilibre là des choses alors nous
avons rappelé la loi car ce qui nous a
étonnés en arrivant et c'est vraiment
l'ignorance des textes et de la loi les
règles sont très simples tout
fonctionnaire qui dans l'exercice de ses
fonctions a connaissance d'un crime ou
d'un délit commis sur quiconque et a
fortiori sur un autre français doit
n'ont pas dénoncé doit le signaler il
doit choisir les mots sont très
importants parce que avec des mots comme
délation comme dénonciation on a
renforcé la loi du silence donc doit
signalé ce cas aux procureurs de la
république est ce que j'ai redit aux
enseignants c'est qu'ils ne sont pas les
juges c'est le juge ensuite if hell
enquête
donc il faut que l'effet soit avérée dès
que l'enfant se confie et evergrey c'est
terrible organisent eux-mêmes des
confrontations
au contraire j'ai là où les dérapages
commence à se faire du tout ils ont ils
saisi le jus le parquet le procureur de
la république et c'est lui qui fait son
enquête
le problème se pose lorsque il y à des
rumeurs des on dit et c'est là où en
effet il faut être très prudent à ce
moment-là il diligente une enquête
nous allons les appuyer pour cela dans
shake avec le climat turn en interne
mais pas tout seul parce que il est il
ne s'est pas trop iapr forcément un
fonctionnaire a peur de ce qu'il va
déclencher ne sait pas comment s'y
prendre donc la décision que nous venons
de prendre c'est de créer des lieux de
ressources dans chaque inspection
académique avec un médecin une
assistante sociale un juriste qui va
épauler l'enseignant le directeur du de
loin les cinq heures en fait on vit bien
sûr que je crois tout le monde a envie
d'un lieu où l'on parle où l'on discute
où l'on se demande ce que l'on va faire
mais cela uniquement lorsqu'il ya des
rumeurs il faudrait être bien clair
chaque fois qu'un enfant fait état de
sévices
chaque fois que les faits sont avérés
c'est le procureur de la république tout
de suite dès lors qu'il s'agit de
rumeurs à son iphone est une enquête
fait lieu de ressources vont être mis en
place dans les académies au ministère de
l'éducation nationale
également et nous allons épauler la
communauté éducative pour faire face à
ce problème très difficile mais je crois
que c'est une bonne chose que cette
libération de la parole et le
gouvernement a décidé de faire des
droits de l'enfant une de ses priorités
j'ai beaucoup de questions à vous poser
sur des questions d'actualité sur la
rentrée d'abord sur l'île noire comme
autant sur le bac c'est une bonne cuvée
comme vous le savez déjà les premiers
résultats sont arrivés les résultats
définitifs auront lieu mardi donc et
encore d attente angoissée des candidats
je crois que le baccalauréat serait une
bonne cuvée le baccalauréat garde tout
son niveau c'est un diplôme de grande
qualité
moi je voudrais d'abord féliciter ceux
qui vont être sûr remercié tous les
enseignants qui ont conduit nos enfants
de la maternelle au baccalauréat leur
dire aussi c'est que nous allons
réfléchir et nous allons agir pour que
augmente encore la proportion d'élèves
qui ont le bac nous en sommes à 65 %
d'une classe d'âge
nous nous fixions un objectif de 80 %
d'une classe d'âge je voudrais dire
aussi à tous ceux qui n'ont pas le
baccalauréat vous à voir aujourd'hui que
70 mille enfants sortent du système
scolaire
sans diplôme validé que nous allons
trouver des solutions pour que chaque
enfant sortent du système scolaire avec
la mise en valeur de ce qu'il a acquis
car il a appris les choses mais là des
talents quelque part et nous allons
mettre en place de nous de nouvelles
qualifications qui vont permettre à tous
les enfants tous les jeunes de sortir du
système scolaire en étant valorisé d'une
façon ou d'une autre très rapidement sur
le sur le la rentrée notamment qui avait
été marqué la précédente par beaucoup de
conflits à propos de classe qui était
fermé oui des griffin des situations
dramatiques puisque le gouvernement
précédent avait supprimé 5000 classe
alors il doit aujourd'hui qu'elle je dis
que j'ai déjà souvent a décidé de
réouvrir des classes un nombre important
de classe
nous allons les faire en regardant plus
près ce qui s'est passé sur le terrain
c'est à dire en donnant une priorité aux
secteurs ruraux fragiles et aux zones
urbaines où les publics scolaires ont
besoin qu'on leur donne plus parce
qu'ils ont moins et je voudrais dire
aussi qu'à la rentrée tous les enfants
mangeront à leurs fins le gouvernement
mis en place un fonds social pour les
chantiers qui a été débloqué récemment
et trois cent mille enfants vont enfin
pouvoir accéder à ce droit élémentaire
qui celui de manger à sa faim mais si on
veut que d'avoir accepté notre
invitation ce soir